fois qu'on essaye de réformer ce gros
mach à un reee réformable jeu enfin il
ya quelque chose qui se passe alors 25 %
des étudiants qui rentre à l'université
ont leur licence en trois ans mais 75%
il échoue lamentablement
c'est l'hécatombe donc il faut régler le
problème cette même ministre qui ce
matin n'était pas complètement pertinent
de semble-t-il a quand même promis 950
millions d'euros sur cinq ans pour
réformer l'université ben écoutez je
réjouissons nous c'est une cote mal
taillée aujourd'hui mais on va voir
d'abord un lieu où tout le monde pour
l'université où j'ai déjà que l'esprit
des deux lycées pour leur demander de
rendre des avis de former les élèves de
donner un avis sur est-ce que cet élève
est capable de rentrer dans cette
filière c'est déjà très bien pourvu que
les choses soient coordonnées que ce
soit la démarche pour moi qui suis
contente de voir que on essaye oui mais
connaissait même pas une question d'état
d'esprit qui n'arrivent pas à changer
complètement n'est pas tout 101 106 et
cette idée qu'on a tous droit à
si vous voulez cette espèce dessus en
otage je précise que les jeunes sont
assez d'accord avec vous puisque selon
un sondage récent 61% d'entre eux sont
favorables à une sélection sur dossier à
l'entrée de l'université